Wolfgang renenberg sie normalerweise
frage ich am Anfang immer wie ist die
Lage ich mach's diesmal ein bisschen
komplizierter und zwar sie waren das
kann man sagen Leiter der Atomaufsicht
in Deutschland also der der
entsprechenden Abteilung im
Bundesumweltministerium ja ich war der
fachliche Leiter der atomaufs sich in
Deutschland so kann man das sagen ja
heute aktuell eine Meldung und da sind
wir dann bei der Lage die Strahlung in
den entsprechenden Kernkraftwerken in
Fukushima
beschreibt und da steht dass 22
millionenfache der normalen
Strahlendosis wird da gemessen da sind
ist einmal von 46 sit pro Stunde die
Rede im Block 1 52 Block 2 60,5 im Block
3 uns allen sagen diese Zahlen überhaupt
nichts ist das was schlimmes oder können
Sie daraus lesen was da los ist man hat
ja so ein bisschen den Eindruck da ist
Nachrichtensperre ist ist kaum was zu
hören aus
Fukushima was interpretieren sie
daraus diese Zahlen bedeuten äh schlicht
weg dass das tödliche Dosen sind also
mit 46 si pro Stunde
da
fällt man Tod um
wenn man eine Stunde da drin ist
die tödliche Dosis beginnt bereits
vorher wenn man mehr als acht sit
aufgenommen hat dann ist es fast sicher
dass man das nicht überlebt das sind
einfach Größenordnung in denen kann sich
keiner aufhalten da können die Arbeiter
auch nicht arbeiten da müssen die
abgezogen werden in solchen Bereichen
das macht die Sache natürlich schwierig
das macht die schwierig denn wenn man
dort ja Wasser rein äh spülen muss auf
welche Weise auch immer aber dann dabei
Tod umfällt dann äh geht das halt so
nicht ja das geht einfach nicht äh und
das macht äh auch die Rettung dieses
Reaktors oder diese Reaktoren so
schwierig das heißt was ist denn ist es
wird ja immer diskutiert gab es eine
Kernschmelze gab's keine Kernschmelze
was ist da jetzt passiert
ja das wissen die Leute vor Ort ja auch
nicht denn wenn sie da reingucken würden
dann würden sie ja nicht erst nach einer
halben Stunde tod umfallen sondern
würden sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht
reinkommen also das ist die Strahlung
ist dort so intensiv drin da kann man
nicht einfach reingehen und reingucken
und den Messinstrumenten zu vertrauen
ist auch praktisch nicht mehr möglich
weil dort ja so viel zerstört ist und
man nicht weiß ob die Messinstrumente
nur das richtige sagen oder nicht
äh deswegen kann man das nur vermuten
was da passiert und äh ich halte es
persönlich für wahrscheinlich dass bei
solch hohen Strahlendosen
äh keine keine Schutzhülle mehr um das
was da ja im Kern strahlt um das Uran
mehr vorhanden ist jedenfalls zum Teil
nicht mehr vorhanden ist äh weil das
eine Erklärung dafür wäre dass da jetzt
so hohe Strahlen sind das heißt
eigentlich alles das was man im
Kernreaktor machen muss nämlich die
verschiedenen ja wie eine Zwiebelschale
innere Hülle noch Hülle noch Hülle noch
Hülle das ist jetzt alles frei
offensichtlich kommt das dann auch ins
Wasser rein
was
was dort was dort rum steht und führt
dann eben zu solch hohen Strahlendosen
aber ich glaube nicht dass das überall
der Fall sein wird sonst könnten die
Leute da gar nicht mehr arbeiten sondern
das wird an den sag mal ganz Entscheid
oder ganz wenigen Stellen wird diese
hohe Strahlenbelastung vorhanden sein
heißt das denn es hat eine Kernschmelze
gegeben oder spielt das dann überhaupt
noch keine Rolle ob es eine gegeben hat
oder nicht die Strahlung ist so stark
dass es sowieso alles für die Strahlung
ist es erstmal egal ob es da eine
Kernschmelze gegeben hat oder nicht dass
entscheiden ist nur dass die Strahlung
da so hoch ist da muss man sich dran da
vorsehen aber vielleicht muss man dann
noch mal das Thema wechseln und und zu
dem zu dem zu dem Reaktor kommen was ist
überhaupt eine Kernschmelze
was ist daran das gefährliche wie
passiert sowas und was ist das
schlimmste Szenario was man erwarten
kann viele denken ja Kernschmelze ist
sowas wie eine
Atombombenexplosion
manche rechnen schon damit dass da
irgendwann Atompilz zu sehen ist das ist
es aber nicht es ist die Kernreaktion im
Reaktor so oder so hat wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe gerade bei
diesem Reaktortyp hat aufgehört weil es
ein ein mit wasserbetriebener Reaktor
ist der braucht Wasser um überhaupt eine
Kernreaktion zu haben bei diesem Reaktor
ist es anders
das heißt aber da ist trotzdem was
schlimmes was ist denn wenn es keine
Kernreaktion mehr gibt was warum so ja
das ist genau das typische für eben
solche Atomreaktoren da kann man mal
zwear da kann man zwar diese sogenannte
Kettenreaktion abstellen also dass das
Feuer dauernd wieder neu angefacht wird
äh da kann man den Stecker rausziehen ja
dann wird die Wärmeproduktion in diesem
Kern von 100% ums etwa das 20fache
reduziert und es sind etwa nur so 5 6 7%
noch an an an Leistung ja an
Wärmeentwicklung in diesem Kern da aber
diese 5 bis 7% die kann ich nicht
ausstellen das ist genau der Unterschied
zu einem Feuer da kann ich dann ja in
einem großen Kohlekraftwerk kann man
sich vorstellen da könnte man z.B mit
Feuerwehrschläuchen reinhalten und dann
geht das Feuer aus das kann man das kann
man da nicht da kann man nichts das kann
man nicht löschen man kann es nicht
löschen
wenn man Wasser drauf tut einfach
normales Wasser besteht sogar die Gefahr
dass das nukleare Feuer wieder angeht
also ist es sogar sogar sogar gefährlich
da einfach nur s waserauf zuun äh dass
sie im Moment Wasser darauf tun die
kalkulieren ein D dass sie die
Kernreaktion an anfachen ja die gehen
jetzt davon aus dass sie äh diese diese
Schwierigkeiten nicht haben die hatten
ja auch zu Anfang gesagt dass sie ein
Zusatzmittel zu diesem Wasser reintun
müssen nämlich Bohr ja der das Bohr äh
das das das
absorbiert also das hält die Teilchen
auf die zwischen diesen
Brennstäben herumfliegen und immer immer
wieder ein neues Atom Spalten ja wenn
ich die einfange dann können die keine
mehr Spalten und dann gibt's keine
Kettenreaktion ja dazu ist das
SP ja und dann wenn alles schön dicht
ist ist das auch alles wunderbar nur das
Problem ist wenn ich jetzt diese
Brennstäbe die man sich vorstellen kann
wie mehrere Meter lange
tablettenröhrchen ja so ganz dünne
Dinger ja sind so dünne Dinger so
tablettenröhrchen aber natürlich aus ein
starken Metallmantel drum der aber auch
nicht so allzu dick ist pa paar
Millimeter und da sitzen tatsächlich
Tabletten drin ja das sind so Tabletten
ja die sind so vollgefüllt mit diesen
Tabletten nicht ganz bis oben s ein
bisschen Luft drin und das Uran drin ja
das der Kernbrennstoff und das
funktioniert auch wunderbar solange es
eben alles normal läuft aber wenn eben
diese Kettenreaktion abgeschaltet ist
dann sind durch diese ganzen
spaltprozesse also muss man sich
vorstellen da sind diese Atome die
werden getroffen die platzen auseinander
plötzlich sind da zwei andere zwei
andere Teilchen da dies sind völlig
anders ja ist nicht mehr Uran das ist
zäium stronzium Jod da steht da
entstehen alle verschiedenen Stoffe und
diese ganzen verschiedenen Stoffe die
jetzt da drin entstanden
sind die sind jetzt besonders gemein ja
die sind besonders gemein weil die
brauchen nämlich zum großen Teil gar
kein Neutron mehr also kein Teilchen
damit sie sich spalten sondern die
Spalten sich spontan also die das
plötzlich zack ja Spalten die sich ja
und das da kommt erstens Strahlung raus
ja da kommt die Strahlung raus die
tringt und die muss aufgehalten werden
durch Beton durch das Metall und so
weiter so dass das im Normalbetrieb
sieht man das gar nicht das ist kein
Problem aber wenn jetzt natürlich alle
Hüllen weg sind dann äh dann kommt das
raus dann kommt diese Strahlung raus und
zwar in Form von Gas ja also das ist die
stehen unter Druck diese Röhrchen dann
braucht das nur oben beschädigt zu sein
dieses Röhrchen und dann zischt das
radioaktive Gas raus und sofort mess ich
draußen sol ich eine Erhöhung von strah
werden fällt dann meistens wieder ab
weil das dann wegwäht ja und dann weiß
man aber hoppla da drin ist wieder was
kaputt gegangen und genau das ist das
was wir da feststellen also immer da
wenn es solche Strahlen Erhöhung geht
hoppla da ist wieder was Kap drin
Brennelemente gibt es ca
250 400 also das hängt vom vom Reaktor
ab und in jedem
Brennstab sind noch mal eine Vielzahl
jedem Brennelement das sind so
zusammengefasste Bündel ja wie so diese
tablettenröhchenbüen in jedem
Brennelement sind da noch mal
äh also unglaublich viele also sind weiß
nicht 100 150 oder so Brennstäbe drin
das he 250 mal 150 ST ganz viele Stäbe
dr dieser Stäbe kann und jeder dieser
Stäbe kann kaputt gehen die sind
unabhängig die sind nicht miteinander
verbunden ja und diese Stäbe wenn die
halt undicht werden kann man sich ja
vorstellen dann geht eben das was ich da
an Stoffen gebildet habe mit da ist auch
Gas also hedelgas B sich dann das geht
raus und es diffundieren natürlich auch
Teilchen raus und je nachdem wie stark
das kaputt gegangen ist kommt mehr raus
diffundieren heißt es dringt einfach
diffundieren dringt einfach eben raus ja
es tringt einfach raus das Kühlsystem
ist da komplett kaputt und das
Kühlsystem ist kaputt das heißt das kann
immer noch so eine große Hitze bilden
dass es alles durchschmilzt und
verklummt diese Masse ja das wird wie so
eine Lava und diese Lava die schmilzt
einfach weiter da kann ich da kann ich
Wasser drauf tun ja es passiert es wird
einfach das die Hitze wird weiter
produziert ja das heiß das schmilzt dann
unten durch das kann dann im schlimmsten
Fall schmilzt das unten durch das ist ja
schwer ja das besteht ja viel schwer
Metall
und das setzt sich dann unten auch auf
den Sicherheitsbehälter drauf wenn es im
aus dem Reaktor Druckbehälter raus ist
und dann schmilzt es auch das durch und
kann dann in den Beton rein und je
nachdem irgendwann wird's vielleicht
aufgehalten weil es sich dann verteilt
ja und
dann
dann ja köchelt es sozusagen vor sich
hin wie eine Lava die aber ganz ganz
langsam erkaltet und dann kann man
eigentlich nur noch Sand drauf tun damit
sich das dann verbindet ein bisschen mit
dem Sand das wird dann eine glasartige
Masse und Versuch kann es versuchen es
abzudichten versuchen dass es nicht ins
Grundwasser kommt
und dann letztlich versuchen zu
verschließen sass dann auch da keine
radioaktive Strahlung mehr in die Umwelt
gelangt aber das ist dann ein langer
Prozess und während des ganzen Prozesses
t das und strahlt und gibt seine Stoffe
auch an die Luft ab und das verweht ins
Land und macht die Strahlenbelastung es
ist hier natürlich im Augenblick noch
unabsehbar man kann das nicht
vorhersagen wie schnell sie das schaffen
also insbesondere wenn man da 10 000 km
weg ist und man müsste auch die Anlage
natürlich genau kennen wie aufgebaut ist
und die jetzigen Zerstörungen ich weiß
nicht ob die Japaner das tun aber ob sie
das kennen aber wie gesagt da stehen
ganz viele Fragezeichen vor der
schlimmste Fall ist dass eben alles
austritt und die Kernschmelze in der
freien Umgebung liegt und dann alles was
dort an Radioaktivität austreten kann
auch Austritt das wird dann noch mal ein
ganz ander noch mal eine schlimmere
Katastrophe jetzt hat die
Bundesregierung ja von einem auf den
anderen Tag reagiert und mal alle alten
Meiler abschalten lassen in Sachen
Sicherheitsüberprüfung die Frage ist
kann denn überhaupt hier sowas Pass
ieren oder sind unsere Kern man man hat
ja vorher im Vorhinein gedacht Japan
super sicher die kennen Erdbeben die
sind auf alles vorbereitet hat sich dann
als nicht richtig herausgestellt in
Deutschland geht man eigentlich auch
davon aus aber die Bundesregierung traut
dem Braten jetzt auch nicht mehr traut
sie dem nicht mehr kann man dem nicht
trauen dass ein Kernkraftwerk sicher ist
was uns ja hier wie lange gibt's
Kraftwerke 50 Jahre Kernkraftwerke 50
Jahre erzählt worden ist oder sind die
deutschen Kernkraftwerke
sicher also also man wenn man wenn man
eine Woche vor dem Reaktorunglück in
Japan in Japan eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung durchgeführt
hätte bzw mit der zu Ende gewesen wäre
und den Bericht veröffentlicht hätte
dann hätte die japanische Behörde
bestimmt gesagt und auch die Betreiber
unsere kernkraftwerke sind
sicher bei uns ist auch so ja es gibt
Sicherheitsüberprüfung und noch vor
wenigen wenigen Tagen
oder zu wenigen Wochen haben viele
gesagt die deutschen Kernkraftwerke sind
sicher da kann das gar nicht
passieren solche Aussagen sind
beschränkt verwertbar ja sind beschränkt
verwertbar und zwar deshalb weil es
immer eine Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt dass
solch ein Kernkraftwerk versagt man kann
es nicht absolut sicher machen das geht
nicht das war in Japan nicht so es in
Deutschland auch nicht so und es gibt
auch solche B Rechnung in den man dann
theoretisch sich alle möglichen
schadensmöglichkeiten überlegt und sagt
ja wie passiert das und das und das und
dann berechnet man wie wahrscheinlich
ist das eigentlich dass es dann mal
endgültig knallt da kriegt man dann
zahlen raus die sind diese hören sich
relativ klein an die sind so im Mittel
ja pro Jahr sagt man pro Anlage habe ich
eine Chance von ein zu 100.000 oder ein
zu 10 000 dass das passiert oder wenn
ich es in Jahren Ausdrücke einmal in
100.000 Jahren ja wenn das so lange
laufen würde das Kernkraftwerk läuft
natürlich nicht so lange würde das
kaputt gehen oder einmal in 10 000
Jahren ich kann man sagen na ja ist ja
nicht so schlimm aber das kann morgen
passieren ja das ist das wie im Lotto ja
im Lotto ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ich gewinne sogar noch viel kleiner so
140 Millionen hö ja aber einer gewinnt
immer ja irgendwann gewinnt einer ja und
genauso ist es in der Kerntechnik auch
irgendwo gibt's immer ein Unfall die
Frage ist nur wann ja und wie schnell
dabei kann es hier sein es kann dort
sein es kann woanders sein und das hat
man jetzt ja auch gesehen es ist nicht
nur in Russland ja es ist nicht nur in
den USA mit Harrisburg ja jetzt ist es
in Japan und es hat ja auch andere schon
beinahunfälle und andere Unfälle in
Russland und woanders gegeben äh bei
denen
auch viel passiert ist aber die eben
nicht so bekannt sind jedenfalls äh gibt
es äh eine Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das
bei uns auch passiert und man muss
natürlich trotzdem noch sagen diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit das ist das der kann
man nicht entrinnen ja das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt das ist
das Restrisiko das ist unentrinnbar ja
da passiert irgendwas was wir nicht
vorhersehen können und wir könn nicht
alles vorhersehen
dann gibt es natürlich aber noch Risiken
die sind vermeidbar und vorhersehbar und
genau darum geht es jetzt insbesondere
bei den alten Anlagen da weiß man ja was
die für sicherheitsschwächen haben und
und das ist nicht ein Restrisiko das ist
nicht unentrinnbar und das ist ein
bekanntes Risiko das ist sag mal das ist
ein da kann man sagen wir wissen heute
wir können wir können den Schutz viel
besser machen als das in diesen
Kraftwerken ist aber es wurde bisher
nicht gemacht weil es den Betreibern zu
teuer war ja schlicht weg das ist der
Grund also das ist als wer würde ich mit
einem Auto fahren was eigentlich nicht
den Tüff bekommen hat ich hoffe aber
dass ich nicht so stark bremsen muss
dass das ein Unfall passiert das meine
funktioniert nicht richtig aber ich
hoffe dass ich sie nicht
so so hart würde ich nicht sagen so hart
würde ich nicht sagen aber ist ein gutes
Beispiel würde ich aufgreifen ja das ist
das gleiche als wenn man heute sagt
ich fahre heute mit einem Z CV ja wenn
ich mit einem 2 CV fahre ich bin selber
damit gefahren ich finde das ein super
Auto ja nichts gegen dieses Auto ja aber
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich bei
einem Crash in diesem Auto umkomme wenn
ich mit einem Mercedes zusammenstoße ist
relativ groß und deswegen weil diese
autokonstruktion und die
Sicherheitstechnik früher ja auch noch
viel unsicherer war hatten wir gab's
allein in Deutschland Z 15 000 Tote 17
000 Tote teilweise pro Jahr allein
aufgrund von Verkehrsunfällen wenn man
da noch mal dazu rechnet die Zahl von
Verkehrsunfällen in in der damaligen DDR
dann würde man weit über 20.000 25 000
kommen heute mit der besseren
Sicherheitstechnik die fahren ja nicht
ja die fahren ja nicht vorsich die heute
die Leute ne also wenn man da merkt mir
häufig heute gibt es im
Gesamtdeutschland
unter 4000 Tote im Jahr das ist ein
Faktor von 5 oder se weniger so ähnlich
muss man sich das mit den
Kernkraftwerken vorstellen die alten
Typen sind eben e um solche Faktoren
vielleicht D 4 5 oder sechs Mal
unsicherer als das was man heute bauen
würde sogar schon gebaut hat also
schlechter als die die schon 20 Jahre
alt sind und zu den neueren
gehören das bedeutet einfach dass man
dieses Risiko jetzt eingeht wenn man die
alten Anlagen weiter betreibt und genau
diesen Beschluss hatte die
Bundesregierung ja gefasst mit den
Laufzeitverlängerung wusste man aber
schon das ist jetzt nichts Neues nach
Fukushima und wenn man jetzt diese
Anlagen vom Netz nimmt dann ist das gut
und schön aber das hat nichts mit einem
Lernprozess zu tun weil das war bekannt
ja das war bekannt aber noch mal auf
diese den Mercedes entenvergleich wenn
man jetzt die Deutsche
kernkraftwerkslandschaft nimmt was haben
wir darum stehen haben wir irgendwo
Mercedes oder sind es alles nur
endenkäer ja also es
ist richtig hier frage ich äh äh sehe
etwa diese sieben Kraftwerke die jetzt
vom Netz genommen sind das sind äh das
sind die Enten ja das sind die Enten
dazu gehört noch
Krümmel das ist eine dyan ja das ist
also eine Ente Luxus ja besser ausgest
ja eine luxusente und äh dann haben wir
dazwischen äh modernere äh paar
modernere ähm Kraftwerke äh vielleicht
aus den 90er Jahren äh und
äh ja das modernste das modernste Auto
ist tatsächlich Anfang der 90er Jahre
was was heute tatsächlich läuft und den
Mercedes haben wir auch nicht ja also
den heutigen Mercedes der im Jahr 2010
oder 2011 gebaut worden ist äh den gibt
es nicht aber S-Klasse Anfang der 90er
kann man schon sagen das kann man schon
sagen ja das ist der große Vergleich da
waren schon Airbags drin glaube ich ja
ja da waren Airbags drin da sind die
Gurte dabei ja und da waren auch schon
Kopfstützen und außerdem knautchzonen
und alles dies was
die äh den den Schutz doch erheblich
verbessert aber noch kein ABS noch kein
ESP und so weit undort ja genau genau
und
wenn man diesen Vergleich macht dann
kommt man eben dazu dass es einfach
dass die alten Kraftwerke um Faktoren ja
schlechter sind als diejenigen die neuer
sind es gibt also es gibt bedeutende
Meinung in Deutschland die sagt die
deutschen Kraftwerke für die deutschen
Kraftwerke
ähm ist für die erdbebenauslegung zu
wenig getan ja also denn man muss
eigentlich mit stärkeren Beben rechnen
als man das so ein unterstellt hat bei
der Planung sagt man wie stark
schüttelst denn jetzt dann bei einem
Erdbeben und wenn ich dann sage na ja so
stark wird's ja nicht schütteln ja und
und und Beben
dann sage ich okay muss jetzt
Kernkraftwerk ja auch nicht so stabil
bauen wenn man dagegen hohe antfort
Forderung stellt dann müsste man es viel
stärker bauen und genau das ist die die
Diskussion man müsste also heute noch
mal nach jetzigem Stand von Wissenschaft
und Technik alle Standorte überprüfen
stimmt denn überhaupt ja die Stärke des
Erdbebens die wir da angenommen haben
oder S nicht viel stärker ja das ist
eine Aufgabe die man die die wichtig
wäre und da habe ich meine Zweifel ob
das
ob dann die erdbebenauslegung von das
betrifft nicht nur alte Anlagen
von einigen Anlagen dann ausreicht oder
nicht heute sieht man ja alles was
theoretisch möglich ist das passiert
auch ja es passiert irgendwann irgendwo
und Entsorgung und
diese Unfallgefahr das waren ja auch
zwei Dinge das hat damals den
Gesetzgeber im Jahr 2002 ja in der
Begründung kann man es nachlesen dazu
gebracht sag mal jetzt stellen wir das
ab ja wollen klar Fahrplan haben das
abzustellen ja und dann ging es
andersrum und jetzt ich weiß nicht wo es
hingeht ja und es werden ja sogar neue
kankftwerke auf weltweit gebaut man
zweifelt ja an der Vernunft ja das es
werden aber insbesondere dort neue
Kernkraftwerke gebaut wo diejenigen die
die bezahlen müssen das Risiko auf den
stat abwälzen auch in in USA ist es so
äh dass die dort äh ganz große
Kreditgarantien bekommen
äh diejenigen die neue Kernkraftwerke
bauen in Milliarden Höhe sonst könnten
das gar nicht finanzieren sonst würde
denen keine Bank Geld geben und sie
würden es auch selber nicht wollen jetzt
haben Sie die Sicherheit wenn ich es
nicht mehr bezahlen kann ja und sich das
als nicht wirtschaftlich erweist dann
bezahlt der Staat unter der Bedingung
bauen sie wenn sie das nicht hätten
würde dort keiner eine Anlage bauen das
gleiche ist in China da ist es der Staat
die die selber baut in Indien ist es
auch nicht anders und in allen anderen
Ländern wird es ganz ganz schwierig das
wäre denn ihre Lösung für ener für die
Energie Krise die diese Länder ja
befürchten wenn sie keine Atomkraftwerke
bauen ja das kann ich jetzt nicht für
alle Länder kann man das natürlich nicht
über einen kamampscheren äh aber
ähm sag mal für die meisten Länder äh
gibt es Möglichkeiten äh äh dies äh
Wasser auf eine andere Art und Weise
heiß zu machen denn was anderes ist es
ja nicht ja es ist ein großer Kochtopf
ja ist ein großer Kochtopf den ich ja
hab und
äh äh es gibt
ähm die Sonne die wir kennen mit
Photovoltaik
äh da wird direkt Strom erzeugt dann
gibt es
den Wind den gibt es
fast überall
den kann man im Meer nutzen den kann man
in Gebirgen nutzen äh und es
gibt dann da drüber hinaus
beispielsweise in Island ja die die
holen Ihre gesamte Wärmeenergie aus den
aus den heißen Quellen die sie dort
haben äh und damit kann man sogar dann
auch schon auch noch Strom erzeugen also
letztlich sind es die Erneuerbaren es
gibt Gezeitenkraftwerke es gibt
Wasserkraftwerke
man kann auch Strom aus Afrika
importieren in Afrika gibt es so viele
Flächen man könnte dort beispielsweise
auch wenn es zu weit ist aus dem Strom
dort Wasserstoff produzieren und den
Wasserstoff dann mit Tankern wo anders
hin fahren wie eben heute
Erdöl also es gibt ganz ganz viele
Möglichkeiten und die Sonne äh hat eine
solche Energie äh dass sie zichfach
äh das deckt was wir hier brauchen eben
über Wind über Wind über überströmungen
auch letztlich die Wasserkraftwerke ist
ja nichts anderes als emporgehobenes
Wasser ja es wird in die Berge über den
über den Regen in die in die Großen Seen
reingebracht das fliet runter alles
Sonne es ist alles Sonne ja gut vielen
Dank bitte